atlantic city's
skyline had a major makeover this week
as the former trump plaza hotel and
casino was blown up in a controlled
demolition
there was even an auction to sell 10
seats for an implosion viewing party at
another space with clear views of the
former president's
former casino according to the mayor of
atlantic city
marty small the road to get here was
tedious
trump opened the plaza hotel and casino
in 1984.
it was one of three casinos in atlantic
city with the trump name
amidst great hoopla this week donald
trump is opening his 1 billion
taj mahal casino in atlantic city the
other two were the trump taj mahal
which is now the hard rock cafe and
trump marina
now the golden nugget following several
bankruptcies
lagging revenue and rising competition
from other resorts
trump took the casinos public which
shifted the risk to stockholders
many many a small business contractors
small family businesses went belly up
when he
didn't pay them the crumbling and
dilapidated plaza hotel and casino
eventually closed down in 2014
being bought out by billionaire investor
carl icahn
who had supported trump in the 2016
presidential campaign
the building was supposed to come down
earlier but faced many delays
there was an auction in december for the
right to press the detonator but it was
cancelled after receiving a cease and
desist letter from one of icon's
companies
for the record the highest bid was 175
000 in its heyday the plaza hotel and
casino
was the entertainment hub of atlantic
city it hosted all the mike tyson fights
as well as wrestlemania 4
and 5. but it's not clear what will
replace the venue
an icon has yet to release any plans for
the future of the site
mayor small says the city is hoping it's
not another casino